hello and welcome to this video let's
play some more games um ii try to do
this video the first one I try to get
some some rapid game going and it took
me like I was in the video for four
minutes and I simply didn't get a game
it was a bit odd um I'm just going from
blitz games he +2 looking quite fine a
moment each as is experiencing how many
new players coming in the general
situation all over the world
Oh
are you
so
waiting time
thank you I was into my own repertoire
exam
we were placed to be played most always
you
those between CA but Queen b6 you get
I'm
I think taking only three is the most
principal the worst
if everyone is a funny move threatening
for winning a piece
yeah this is not the kind of like to
play until you have to
you
queen is some blue misplaced
I'm not yet Britany egg
em to make
as to cool it
leaving behind a very bad so the
question is do I actually want to do
fianchetto on
and also start with don'ts there anyway
and
could make an make an argument about
playing
on that diagonal
we'll be totally and
first of all I can attack a c7
the real real threat and at neig on
you
a here III does make some sense
and show
X square
a bit strange with the GTA III but the
bishop is really better now only two
a
you
okay yeah I can just take one
but simple wagered
you
reddening b5
and don't see how he stops it really
you
I
a very strong protected c5 point
now he tries to play e5 but the moment I
manage b5 this is kind of impossible was
d5 is so weak
Oh a point and I understand that he
wants to do something but they don't
really think books
okay yeah
best with this
asking the Queen about William
after Willie
95 76
all of that to use create
we can take on five
you
could even take
but
[Music]
the luxury issue again
by many things as threatening Bishop is
60
[Music]
g7
and see play is win the Queen
you
aim
you
aren't just I can
and win immediately
and it looks missing wins but I know
from experience that leaving this is a
difficult
the tricky thing in my games
you
Oh Knight f6
yeah
you
okay I'm taking up seven winners
currently hanging so where do we where
would put it
you
they'll have some squares here Dixon on
end Bishop g4 boys also
you
yeah Lucas attacked by go
you
ever to be
but still em and all asleep
a
of the continuations
yeah many
you
it just has no weight
okay so that was an interesting game at
the opening is just too bad for like
after this Bishop everyone is already
quite critical um he went b5 again I
don't think black has a good solution
may 6
I've a point never you do you're not in
good shape or takes
in NT of options yeah I'm not sure if I
play didn't wave it looks kind of okay
create ooh reasonable I guess heaven and
now this is something where you can
probably
um yet debate Bishop g2 looks more
standard for some gasoline quick
but I like the idea to use this on on
the diagonal and it worked out very well
but I don't know
that's all special and m57 yeah it's
just taken good boy exactly because he
doesn't really account really prevent b5
I think
Oh bx5 Oh a blunder Knight takes e5 my
would have been very painful after
you're already mean this position is
just winning we play it right and the
correct way to do it is just to spend
one tempo you'll cover this and maybe
five Nick because he and absolutely not
stop it and that would be the end of
blacks game
basically like the game was just without
allowing this ethical strike would have
been awful
the position is probably good enough to
not be worse but something like this you
just blundered upon but Blake's position
is not good anyway
Computers tests about equal
okay in the game it rushes it
Robert I probably could have won quicker
anyways
see seven was just a practical solution
because I felt I was doing it playing
too slowly
um yeah the engine gives this a relative
the best way to play
of pawns and this is what he did
that is all and we come in
yeah the opening is just it's not I'm
not really good with basics
okay so one more
Oh is happy to face somebody who has got
the has got a title in there because I
mean it's not a guarantee some more
likely to not play against a GM if you
want to have from your I am or whatever
you have in them um you have to send
your idea - yes
there's a little bit more credibility
there
[Music]
you
you
an interesting line
sloth without
nd
you
six is valid yeah
collectively
like
about
a six is more about addressing apart in
about playing b5
now
after you make up my mind if I want to
plaintiff and I think I ultimately have
to play this
under
wonder about night age on its this he
never played age six which often play we
have a convenient square
No age 7
let's see III now I have a strategic
read this didn't react to o5f for that
was a strategic threat
and now black has to be very careful was
have this bind in the center and I have
interesting wants to go
I've visiting
though like
maybe he wants to play Fi
who
yes stop and hikes
yes
you
you
listen
you
I wonder about G for now for me this is
a move that is of course desirable
strategically speaking but I wonder
about the timing
I play something like eg by then I flip
a
yeah
like
you
oh I don't really know difficult of
you
since you just
you
yeah this isn't it's not not that
fantastic
that was a good way to explain it well
with 9h seven and so on and was I think
a good way to play
okay I'm just going to shut down this
thing but this is not a very beautiful
move
I don't want to
a some
I
opening files again
he did a good job him
you
wonder if I'm Lucia or if it is still
equal
but it's ultimately still difficult for
black to
I want to eat
second
anyway
you
and when you have one idea left
profiles on
um
I'm doing here son being up
you
to use the King to caliz somehow
you
loli get their King f1e - he has no
entry squares
side
you
our king ichigen isn't even doing that
much and always play plain at age five
and so let's correct this yeah
the bishop actually should be on c1 that
that that looks better
and better doesn't mean that that I'm
happy with
you
eebee Chemical pairs and of
before
I had an idea with all this stuff this
is the danger that if you find something
coming that all of a sudden the time is
a factor but now I'm threatening Bishop
c1 bishop see to reppin the Queen
but be a problem for them maybe yes too
right
every overlooked
you
you know he did
yeah I didn't didn't do a good job here
lucky
you
I was super lucky if he more or less out
it means his position um so here this is
good if I get in like g4g five or
something but I don't I just don't and I
like this this is a good way to claim um
this way Bishop d3 was about trying to
stop g5
and he went f5 correctly and this is it
seems good I don't have the time to play
G form if I would be able to play um
warm and g5 this would be great because
then he would be completely boxed in but
I don't
after this he plays g5 himself in
edgewise engine was also worried about
yeah any case that doesn't look
beautiful and yeah and this is now very
very small chess with g35 given by the
engine let alone this is also pretty
good and I was worried about this g5
business so I tied it to shut it down
but this is pretty not not attractive
yeah I think it's just um and uh not
much is happening here the computer
gives like a fairly this Vantage not
sure that this is really the case would
be that the position is too close for
him to ever do you know not sure it's
clear that I hopes of sacrificing maybe
I have a very slim in term problem the
main issue here was that
simply blundered
you
and it was
I'd be 80s - he just has to do and be
hate and return and we are continuing
but
in just a quick break the video
back
Rick and maybe one or two more games
have many a new account
ready to
[Music]
let's do something a little bit on
you
it's a bit early but why not
Oh f5 can also
you know it's not my style to do this
but maybe it was something completely
different kind of adventurous
they like gata Kamsky just the hippo
let's just try this I mean I don't think
it's a particularly great opening but
once in a while it's not bad idea to
just let's say tickle your mind a little
bit and do something
totally different
now I was thinking
and yeah
actually have a double it
Oh
you
by I can't
you
I'd
very ugly
it's ugly but but be good huh true I
know
you
kind of having no clue here it's a it
looks a bit strange
yeah my bishop mb7 is Italy wrong in
this pawn structure but
and all doesn't look too beautiful
Oh he wants to play a quick
you
see how I can be played without let's
let's castle
you
you
it doesn't have that much pressure on
Excel a Miam this is feasible like c5-b
takes beat eggs Knight f6 relatively
quickly getting some pressure against
also and if you play c5 here with why'd
you weaken d5 and that I'd be important
this is here this is not how harmonious
doesn't have or for example we're
covered
it tries to repair
not so easy now I could take twice on on
and play and play b5
books in logic
you
making some sense of mine b7 visual
my his his nights and don't connect to
so does the recount b-complex
but you never know
although strategic considerations ice on
butt and stir
[Music]
eggie tactical blunder arm and the
misjudgment i deaf
at the sea
book TC I can play
my knight is covering the ship so coming
a thing
not work really well this or concept now
of the bishops
I don't see a movement the the rook is
hanging and I'm threatening or this is a
fairly
[Music]
like rookie on
I can win the exchange yeah taking him
check I guess iam age form
you
I have this coming
Plus before would hang also something
act and do power that it worked out
noise
yeah here a $4
evam
you
and to claim H Phi
by this
you
[Music]
into f1
early in the day but still I can't see
that stinks
okay so one's a rematch let's do that
give me my rematch and then I will check
out the two games together
and wrap the video up
door opening maybe we get it kids in
by the while the ocean
you
you forgotten him
[Music]
you
we
this is where the f5 is one position
where hi yes yes I
and this is the other way of
name
so have to
press em
- pc5 is a thing but really
or ism and we've come from Norma here
cool
you
I'm just relieved
much
but I get beef in ultimately and
it's the loss of time
you
so it should takes now is this is an
inconvenient moment egg
have a long speech yeah because I know
that before it's my move
really see anything else
have to get the pawns going and
they're kind of what else is a key
aching um and be good but not when
Bishop takes a five is hitting me with
the temple he have nine
knowing what so it must strange eat
first on
almost universally used
now
II quit through
you
or takes has a couple of things going
for it yes I'd be 3a I'll be 305 the
thing
okay
you
yeah I can just
you
not worried about the king protect him
in check
Eames lost but we know but
would be a bit odd nights here and the
other 90 M
so Queen c7 add the question
a guy dc-8 and then night CP is some
kind of
kind of stuff for
you
I don't I don't see it
it's just too much I mean this is such
an important pawn
and take it let's see
don't see why it cannot be taken you
have to do
it's a structure porn it it's the whole
porn chain together
more important than let's say a random
on on the edge of the board
really Queen trade
um
[Music]
you
you
hard to believe that this shouldn't be
fantastic right oh yes this night sees
through
prepare knives you
you
it's maybe
you
I know backwards
what is the reply
you
yeah some
games as a
image so let's start with this I cannot
have forgotten your image um it's a
handy normal-looking position so I went
to be 194 was a bit surprised you
usually take on um on before first
and known I'd be five is sting though he
has to
yeah I think pawn takes was more
interesting
get this idea having the square
when Jesus
one that was an alternative sure but I
thought this is made forward and which
was now this is just hanging and well
you cannot take on I mean it has a huge
drawback and here
- falls apart
inbe aids and that come in this looks I
expected this one because I felt I can
probably not take
yeah it's actually a concrete ISM like
this this is some kind of repetition on
the Queen a perpetual on the Queen
so here I would have just returned yeah
and this is not entirely clear you know
in the the night now is not lost and
well black is upon down these sixes and
so on but it's not over the computer is
just evening zero which I find a bit
surprising but maybe this is correct I
mean well it's not the strongest on an
Queen be a death
a king Nazi
[Music]
you just lose the house okay so let's
have a quick look at the aim before
only not way
what's the hippo game young I don't know
maybe before is a bit early here but it
has all the time in the world we should
be we like that
okay before I mentioned c5
I went if I wish it's now this procedure
now to be bad for wider night a to move
fine
and now the computer wants me to castle
and play creep
in logical doesn't like you fight it
seems
and maybe maybe um this Bishop e3 quince
III was
the engine wants to play Knight c3 or
knighted and I mean we later saw that
this this kind of construction was not
so well protected against my f5 b5
chipping away moose and that could be it
could be very reasonable to a this and
also get this lined up
white must be better here at Columbus on
bond plus one
a bishop viii told
III
and here already b5 was okay
probably the engines idea
because of the icy icy
the ideas 95 against him so if he takes
it out
and we see all of a sudden the two
bishops are golden on Devon energy sama
it's really nice the same happens after
c5 which would be the more scary
replying anyway and of taking one but if
Bishop takes seems to be better
and but just yep we nice know b5 didn't
I didn't see that one
it kind of it's possible to see this
move not not for me in a blitz game but
like in general because this is kind of
you know the cesium there are tactics
yeah once you spot like f5 takes e4 you
kind of see that the diagonal is a
pointer
Knight f6
Oh calm skip I've this is really
shutting down any ideas like that not a
happy more and really not but computers
just like being realistic about it
I'd see one and now we have exactly the
game
it's shocking that this is -3 I mean I
kind of failed once I saw the idea that
I must be better but and quite a bit
better but b5 him and his freest
Oh X X
I've guided indeed GLaDOS loose in the
house
and here there were many many ways to
and yes yes so um the hippo not the
greatest opening ever but we see that
and be played successfully in a blitz
game around
okay hope you enjoyed it thanks for
watching